antoine bonjour alors vladimir poutine
s'est exprimé tout à l'heure que retenir
de son discours bien le président russe
a tenu à faire le point à l'issue de la
semaine chaumet décrété mercredi dernier
il a souligné que la situation sur le
front sanitaire était difficile
compliqué mais comme il l'a fait
remarquer en relevant aussi ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays c'est en
limitant au maximum les interactions
entre les gens que l'on parvient à
enrayer la propagation du communisme la
meilleure poutine a donc décidé
d'étendre la période chômée avec matière
de salaire jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'avril écouter pour prendre ses
décisions et il faut bien comprendre que
ce risque se maintient et comme le
disent les spécialistes en virologie le
pic de l'épidémie n'est pas encore
passée et notamment dans notre pays pour
cette raison j'ai pris la décision de
poursuivre cette semaine de congé
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril c'est à
dire jusqu'au 30 avril
avec le maintien des salaires
le président russe a fait savoir que la
situation sanitaire n'était pas homogène
sur tout le territoire us ainsi les
grandes villes comme moscou en premier
lieu était davantage touché les mesures
de confinement sont donc amenés à 6
prolonger voire se durcir al'inverse il
existe des régimes plus faibles où la
situation peut être différente
les autorités locales sont donc priés de
s'adapter d'adapter sur le terrain des
mesures de confinement en fonction de
l'évolution de cette crise sanitaire
enfin vladimir poutine en a appelé à la
responsabilité et la solidarité de tous
ses concitoyens des valeurs
indispensables pour pouvoir surmonter
cette épreuve d'après lui est toujours
avec ce double objectif préserver la
sécurité et la santé de la population
tout en essayant de maintenir l'emploi
une certaine stabilité économique
antoinat merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions